DRN store era at the present era noble
prince Targaryen ish me it is a great
honor to introduce the Nobel laureate in
chemistry professor tomas lindahl
if my step there is conveyor Gator X
Lancer sheriff Printz toga
Mina Domino hello yep a can fire on a
Patil deal as noble prasit humic this a
man's me professor Modric oak professors
under the topic of my brief comments
will be the crucial importance of our
early mentors and teachers I had the
privilege of attending an excellent
state school in Stockholm Brahma even
aciem right
Brahma is a green suburb of Stockholm
close to here I visited yesterday
morning in this school I was fortunate
to have excellent teachers in chemistry
biology mathematics and literature as an
arrogant youngster I took this for
granted but during my upper high school
class class years my family moved to
Central's calm so it seemed convenient
to change school this turned out to be a
minor disaster I did not like the
teachers in the new school and more to
the point the teachers did not like me
in fact one of them failed me in
chemistry
this is an amusing anecdote today but at
the time this was a see this was serious
business because I needed good marks to
be able to enter the Karolinska Medical
School in Stockholm at the later stage
thanks to the concern and help of my
parents I was fortunately able to return
to my previous school and and the
excellent teachers there who supported
me in particular I had inspiring help
from an outstanding chemistry teacher
her name was Colin Brandt mrs. Brandt
encouraged my interest in chemistry and
gave me a good mark thanks to my
improved standing in chemistry I was
then able to enter medical school and
this personal experience of mine shows
how important good teachers can be they
should have our strong and an
enthusiastic support
I had a similar positive experience at
the Karolinska medical school I realized
that an early stage that I might not
become a very good doctor but was
fascinated by theoretical subjects in
particular medical chemistry and
microbiology as a result I started as a
graduate student with a legendary DNA
chemist in our hammer stem he was the
first scientist who showed in his early
work that DNA is a very large molecule a
macro molecule and he created an
important Swedish goal in the field
personally he was like a cat with
intense green eyes and totally
temperamental and inspirational with my
teachers and colleagues at the
Karolinska I learned to think really and
critically and I also learned the
importance of basic science without
outstanding teachers and new insights
from basic science progress in chemistry
and biology would be much slower and
might even come to a standstill thank